hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar exploiting digital histology
approaches
to probe the pathophysiology of sars
kobe 2
infection i'm susie valdez of lab roots
and i will be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and brought to you by leica
biosystems
to learn more visit leicabiosystems.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit
any technical issues here as well if you
have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation i'd
now like to welcome
our speakers kelly hunter digital
pathology analysts
at the molecular histology facility at
the university of
birmingham and dr graham taylor a senior
lecturer at the university of birmingham
for
full biography of our speakers please
click on the biography tab at the top
of your screen welcome to both of you
kelly you may now begin
your presentation
thank you very much um as my name's
kelly hunter and i
work at the birmingham molecular
astrology facility uh here at the
university of birmingham
where a co-facility where we provide
immense chemistry and tissue
multiplexing services as well as
digital slide scanning i'm going to
introduce our facility and some of the
technologies that we
that we offer access to before my
colleagues
describe some work that they've been
doing including work that's
come to our facility um actually my left
arm has just
this minute started aching as i have my
first fighter vacuum this morning which
i think is going to be
quite appropriate
so i want to start with this
hand scroll diagram don't worry about
the contents of it but
i like it because it's the uh
the first concept of the facility that
we drove a few years ago
and sat together in the pub which is
such an alien
concept now that i thought um people
would would all enjoy
sharing that but um effectively the idea
of this facility
um was to
provide a set of complementary platforms
that vary in
either in throughput
and and resolution complexity
that can form a pipeline for
discovery and validation of discoveries
depending on what the well your
question is you can come in um you can
come into this at different points
um this was the the
the workflow recent videos at the time
but i can't really
imagine that in the pub so casually at
the moment it's very strange
so um see our workflows will start this
thing
um and primarily our sustaining
platforms
uh comprise our uh leica bomb rx or
sustainers we started our bond journey
a number of years ago and we have been
collecting them ever since we've got
four now
um and there are there are real
workhorses they provide
uh uh singleplex uh simplex chromogenic
stains um
right the way through multiplex
chromogenic compression stains
um in not just antibody stains but
ish multiplexers as well and isc-ish
combination assays and they also um
i'd be staying for our digital spatial
profiling episode out of detail
later there's also we're also currently
be testing the lunar full comet you can
see on the bottom right there which has
a same module built in which i'll
discuss briefly later and similar to the
and there are other similar products on
the market as well
once we've stained the the slice then
generally our slides get digitized
and the multi-factor slides particularly
need to be digitized to be
interpreted but
we have a leica bright filter scanner
which
we use for um primarily for digitizing
brightfield slides for purposes for
sharing with collaborators uh different
sites across the country and around the
world but it's also used to digitize
chromogenic stains that our researchers
want to perform image analysis on
and have the koi polaris seven colour
whole slide flashing scanner
for our multiplex assays
and the mantra two parallel development
station which is a
complementary microscope and
we have uh as i mentioned we'll
be setting luna for comet which is able
to perform
up to 20 staining cycles um
automated on four different slides and
i'll go into that slightly
i'll go into that later and the
downstream jmx platform which i'll also
uh also talk about more
which has a it's a hybrid
slide scanner and generally instrument
all of that as you can imagine generates
quite a nice
data challenge and so we have a number
of different solutions for managing that
data we have
like a slide manager which
hosts all of this not just all of the
images that come from our
peri 82 scanner but also any other
images generated from other
uh other facilities or from our
collaborators who
um will send us the images to import
into this platform to share alongside
the images we're generating
locally and so this gets used an awful
lot it's
it's designed to feel like a
standard pathology workflow with a slide
tray on the left and you select your
slides to view them on the right you can
make some
annotations for the images as you would
expect
the image the data behind this is stored
in the birmingham environment academic
research which is a
both a research data store and a high
performance competing facility
and that powers a lot of what you'll see
going on the background
this is the platform for the geomix
announcement instrument
which is also accessed by the web
browser
and and it stores it not only stores the
uh fluorescent scans um but also um
the data analysis platform as again i'll
detail shortly
then we'll move on to data analysis
which is a a key part of most of the
the technologies that come out to come
out of our lab so here we're
looking at um a data analysis workflow
uh
from the vector scanner a seven color
threatened image on the left which has
been specially convoluted and i'll
i'll briefly touch on that quite so in a
moment
and that decompleted image has then had
the
we've performed cell segmentation uh on
the second image on the left
and the green objects are the detected
nuclei from the
the blue dappy stain on the left image
and the red line around that is a
an estimated um cell border
the next image along is a tissue
segmentation um
image which show which has separated the
image into different tissue compartments
and then the final image on the right is
cell phenotyping where each of the
objects from the from the second image
each of the cells have been assigned to
phenotype represented
by different colours there
we also have the visuofarm software
which can perform the same multiplex
phenotyping workflows
as you can see in the top left image
there except we also have gpu
accelerated
um deep learning capabilities on this
so that that really accelerates the
tissue segmentation on the the cell
segmentation required at the beginning
of that workflow and but it also
provides other
outputs such as the heat map you can see
the top right and the the disney clock
down in the in the bottom right and
here is the interface for that software
this is the analysis software from the
nanostring generics
on the left you can see the the freshman
slide scans
and down the center you can see the
various probes that are present in the
assay that can be filtered and then on
the right you can see the outputs from
analyses on our combination of those two
two pins on the left and i'll go into
that
that works so shortly
so i'm going to start by talking about
the
the vector polaris workflow and i'm not
going to go into into its details i know
uh um mike cerache has done this
exhaustingly in the past
for us um but just briefly the
um the idea behind this technique is
that we stain all of our markers on a
single slide
first um label them all with different
floral fills
and then we perform a single scanning
step
and what you can see here is a
representation of
all of the fluorophores uh on a single
slide and the various overlap so
although you can see that the the peak
expression
the peak expressions are all at discrete
wavelengths that
the some part of the expression for each
of those colors overlap with other
colors
uh so then this uh the software
um associated with this platform the
inform software
is used to any given pixel
to deconvolute how much of the intensity
captures our pixel a given wavelength
belongs to
which of the markers that are expressing
in that pixel
and so um another representation of that
here and if we choose panty k
as an example the orange bar above the
circle i've just drawn
shows the range of expression uh that
has been captured at that wavelength
and then you can see that represented
this
signal belonging to three different
markers so you've got
some yellow signal coming from cd68 some
orange belonging to
anti-keratin which we which our peak
expression has come from and then also
some signals blind to
pd1 and so the software here will
estimate how much of the signal wants
each of those three markers
and bin them together instead of in a
per
scan channel fashion but there'll be
bins
per marker instead so then you'll end up
with a
computed channel that is enriched for
your
marker um it's also used to remove auto
thresholds from the background signal
so what you end up with here in the top
left sample in image a is a
uh especially convoluted presence image
um
in the bottom left we can see here a
simulated bright field stain and
just sometimes easier to interpret uh
and then
in image c you can see the pancreatic
keratin has by itself you can view it as
an individual stain because we've
deconvoluted the pancreatic character
and pd1 stains that worker over
overlapping with it and you get a clean
clean stain
then you pass it through the image
analysis workflow that i just described
performing
um tissue and cell segmentation
phenotype yourself and then perform high
dimensional analysis
and spatial analyses on the outputs from
that
so the meaningful comment is an example
of a stain image
elite workflow where a lower number of
markers
are stained are applied to the tissue
they're labeled in this case and with an
exosaurus fluorescent dye
you image those markers and then you
elude the whole antibody complex
and then you start again and you keep
repeating the cycles and
layer the image up in a in staining
cycles instead of staining them all that
all at once
which means that you don't need to
perform the spectral decomposition
because you can use
uh chromogens that are sufficiently far
apart on the spectrum now there's no
and then you end up with um
a more high-dimensional image as this i
think this is a 27-plex
image which you
can't actually view which is where um
image analysis becomes essential because
we can't
uh we can't cross simply interpret this
this image
there we go through some mobile
processing before as well as detecting
protein
uh do rna species detection
this these two images here are examples
of the
rna scope assay from acd bio on the left
a multiplex chromosome
and on the right a um multiplex for
of satay and we also combine these
assays with
protein detection on the same slide
and then on top right here we have a
diagrammatic example of the nanostring
distribution profiling assay where we
combine a
three-plex specimen stain
with a targeted roi based
profiling of a larger pro panel
so the workflow here on the landstring
is we start off by staining our sample
with
a panel of either antibodies or rna
species
and at the moment you can stain panels
of around about 100 antibodies or
18 000 up to 18 thousand rna species um
that are conjugated with um barcodes
attached by photo capable photographical
links
we stain that at the same time we stain
a four color
fluorescent stain three three probes and
then use a countertop
we put the slide in instrument and the
slide scans the
uh the fluorescent morphology stain and
you use this morphology image to select
regions of interest that you
are going to target to profile the the
barcoded panel that you've added
the instrument will then iterate around
the rois you selected irradiating with
uv cleaving those uv
linkers and releasing the barcode into
the suspension which is then aspirated
off the slide
and and into a collection plate
we can then count those barcodes and
relate the data back to which our either
came from so
we have a hybrid four color fluorescence
ihc image
with a high dimensional spatial
genomics output here's an example of
the ri selection process and as you can
see
so each of these squares is an roi and
you're able to
cross-section those rise micro dissect
them with the built-in image analysis
tools on the platform
um which allow you to segment
on the threshold stain so in this case
the the the blue marker is a panasonic
keratin which is highlighting the tumor
in the sample
and we've used the onboard image
analysis tools to segment
the hri into two html positive and a
tumor negative roi and they will be
irradiated and collected separately to
have discrete tumor
and tumor microenvironment and measure
measurements
uh if the nurturing genomics i've just
described as the
ms at the histology labs approach to
spatial genomics then uh 10x's vision
assay is the genome genomics approach to
spatial genomics
so this involves taking a section and
applying it to a slide
that has a grid of
rna primers on the slide
and each spot of primers on the plate
has a barcode associated with it which
tells us which spot it the language
belongs to we also stain it
in the same way as we have before with
the fluorescence mythology stain and
image that you digest the
tissue onto the slide and sequence it so
then
what we have is in this case sequencing
data where each transcript can be
related back to
where it came from on the slide and the
output data looks
like this so you get heat maps for um
expression in different areas on the
slide
so a quick summary of the platforms we
have uh we have we
start off with ifc which is uh really
high throughput it's good resolution
we've got single cell resolution
it's only single stains and
and is more validation tool than
discovery tool
then moves on to multiplex which uh
increases complexity slightly to
maybe three or four colors um
with the same resolution and and
fairly comparable throughput you move on
to multiplex
is uh you increase the flexibility
slightly um
at the expense of throughput um but you
may still maintain that resolution
and and you really start increasing the
discovery power
um you move on to complexity you you
lose some throughput in exchange for
moving on to 40 or more um
targets um but that throughput really
makes it a good
uh more relevant discovery tool
and then special transcriptomics which
uh is
um theoretically infinite flex
and we're you know we're running a whole
transcript home at the moment on a
number of different
technologies um but the resolution
suffers in different ways between those
two technologies that are described you
don't get
quite single cell data from either of
them and then you get on the block is
of course murphy um which answers that
problem by
giving you back not just value i've
actually sub-cellular resolution
uh the change at the um at the cost
complexity
so far um but i'm sure that will
increase over time
here's some of the companies that we
work with and the sponsors that helped
us get this facility
off the ground we the mecca astrology
facility
[Music]
takes in both internal academic and
external academic projects
but we're also um we're also setting
establishing a new entity named
berman tisch analytics which is going to
be an industry facing service contract
gcp compliance
uh face to this service um and this is
going to be part of the precision
medicine center which will include
other disciplines such as genomics and
immunology in a in a multidisciplinary
industry contract kind of trial link
facility
now i'm going to pass on to my colleague
dr graham taylor who's going to tell you
what they've been doing
with these technologies and and many
others
okay thank you teddy uh that's a great
introduction to the facility
and i'm going to talk now about our
projects studying
stars kobe 2 infection and tissue let's
use many of the
approaches that kelly has outlined in
his tool
so we've studied uh two different copy
19 related
uh diseases uh the conventional copic 19
infection
in the lungs that can unfortunately
cause people to die
and also covet 19 plus entities
so that's kevin 19 infecting pregnant
women causing them to
have problems with their pregnancies
including stillbirths
so we know a lot from the analysis of
blood samples from kv19 patients about
what happens in the periphery
so patients often have lymphopenia
neutrophilia
we see increases in the range of various
inflammatory cytokines
it's the evidence of t cell activation
and potentially that
those t cells could drive the
hyperinflammatory state in the lungs
that cause so many problems
and of course is evidence of t-cell
exhaustion
we know much less about what happens
actually in the tissues of those
patients
so with that in mind we undertook a uh
study of tissue
provided to us from postmortem
investigations performed in south wales
by dr ester eude and dr gareth leopold
patients were uh included onto the study
if they've had positive stars kv-2 pcr
swag
either in life when they were in
hospital or a swap taken at post-mortem
and depending on the specific consent
that was taken from the relatives of
each of those
individuals we took samples from
different organs
at least heart and long in every case
okay this has been a very challenging uh
both in sort of technically
challenging but also in terms of the
reagents that we have available to us
of course this is a new virus so there's
little precedence in the literature for
what we're going to find
and the reagents of pivot two have been
untested and poorly validated we also
have additional challenges
the tissue is taken from uh post-mortem
so it's not only fixed
there's always a time interval between
when the patient dies and the sample is
taken that can result in
autolysis and degradation therefore
being really robust in the validation of
the reagents we've used in this study
and hopefully that will come a
plus in the data i'll show you shortly
let me start with the study cohort
focused on eight patients three at the
top
in blue a patient that died in the
community from kovic 19
after very short short preceding
symptomology
we also have five patients shown in red
these patients are admitted to hospital
for
quite long periods of time and
unfortunately died from their disease
and so in this talk we'll be focusing on
these early versus late cases
in terms of their fundamental
pathological analysis
both those patients had evidence of
diffuse alveolar damage in their lungs
as we can go from the early patients to
the late patients we see increasing
evidence of the proliferative phase um
alveolar damage
fibrotic phase and five out of eight
patients so what evidence of
organizing pneumonia in one out of eight
patients and looking more closely we see
thrombine four out of eight patients
evidence of secondary infection in five
out of eight here shown neutrophils in
the lungs
and vasculitis in three out of the eight
patients
so kelly's always made a great
introduction to various platforms we
have available to us
now let me tell you a bit about the
workflow so here's our eight
every 19 patients in blue on the left
hand side here
we have various controls we have a
rhinovirus pneumonia
case breathed cases of bacterial
pneumonia
10 cases of non-infectious disease those
retained lung tissues and interestingly
a case of mers
borona virus from the early 2000's
this is another coronavirus that's
somewhat similar to solid cov2
as mentioned earlier we collected lung
and heart tissues from all
eight patients and a range of other
tissues such as upper airway
brain liver kidney and lymph nodes from
a smaller subset of the patients
depending on the consent we were given
on those samples we've prepared tissue
sections
issuing microarrays we've taken scrolls
of tissue
or processing into rna for genomic
analysis
if here's an overview of the assays
we've used we've used
spatial methods here on the left i have
a single plex immunohistochemistry
ohioplex codex and comet multiplexing in
histochemistry
on the right we've got the molecular
methods which are point seek which is
the rna transcriptome analysis
you've also successfully performed
t-cell receptor sequencing
and a range of samples in the middle
item type interesting hybrid methods
these include rna scope which detects
rna
in different parts of the tissue and the
nano string that is already outlined
these are interesting to say combine the
power of transcriptome analysis
is the power of looking at where those
rna molecules are spatially located
localized
in the tissue so just add that for all
of these
spatial methods and hybrid methods we
stay in tissue successfully
either as that's end result for the
method or as preparation for that method
using the um bond system
it might want rx
these are the outcomes from these
different assays the spatial methods
give us high dimensional phenotyping and
localization of specific markers we've
pre-selected within the tissue
of course we can detect virus in those
different regions of tissue
molecular methods are great discovery
tools which allow us to
analyze what genes are expressed
differentially in the different types of
tissue
and also look at pathways using gene set
enrichment analysis
key point here is that we're
cross-validating across all of these
different methods so the spatial methods
the hybrid methods and molecular methods
will support one another
whatever knows is that you need a
histochemistry so if you use a range of
techniques depending on the sample size
on the left here
you've got chromogenic
immunohistochemistry you can use the
lycobond direct system
we've applied that to large areas of
tissue
and on the right here we've used the
highly multiplexer coil codec system
but on smaller tissue microarrays this
is sort of balancing the cost
and the time taken to acquire different
sized images
each of these techniques have their pros
and cons and we've combined them all
together in this study
here's a range of image analysis
techniques to study the data
they've used conventional qualitative
assessment by pathologists looking at
the tissue under the microscope and
here you can see a biped image um
produced on the
uh acquired system the vector system and
on the right here
we're looking at machine learning based
approaches which look at the
data and identify patterns using complex
learning algorithms such as tisny
so here we're showing you the uh geomics
workflow
we won't go into too much detail kelly's
already described it but essentially we
stain the tissue for
pan ck cd45 and for dna then we
uh it illuminates different regions of
that tissue that we
select based on that staining that
cleaves off the uv tube or linkers that
are analyzed on the sequencing
uh in lumina platform
let me show you some results of this
work first of all the virus distribution
in the different tissue
now for a lot of work we've identified a
number of reagents that work well
both on terms of control tissues but
also
have good performance on the ffp heat
issues
so these have all been stained using the
bond direct system from leica
and we've used here viral cells either
uninfected or infected with cells kb2
virus
but here i'm showing you the results
from a spike antibody
not either uninfected or infected in
brown on the right hand side you can see
very good staining
going for the nucleotide uh antibody as
well
at the bottom we're using rna scope so
this is this in situ hybridization
method
that detects particular uh viral
transcripts
over the spike or the off 1abg
you can see the red and the green
screening at the bottom right of the
image here generally positive staining
of those
various infected cells
we've used a range of approaches to
identify whether virus is positive in
different tissue sections
these include immunohistochemistry
institute hybridization using rna scope
and gene expression profiling by quanzi
we've been very robust in how we score
tissue whether it's positive or negative
for the presence of virus
but for example if we see only one
immunohistochemistry marker present
at the bottom of this uh diagram here we
would score that it's negative
c2 meter has immunohistochemistry
markers positive
but no evidence of virus by rna scope we
look very closely at the positive
control rna scope probe result
that is negative that suggests that the
rna may be
poor quality and therefore we score that
as possible
that positive control on a scope is
positive it shows that the rna was good
quality
and therefore we think that the virus is
unlikely to be present because it's
present only
or detected only by at the protein level
but not in the rna level
we see the tissue positive by two main
history
immunohis chemistry markers and by rna
scoping situ hybridization
we scored as likely and we see it's
positive for immunohistochemistry
markers
rna scope and we see evidence of virus
by either
either quantity called geomics gene
expression profiling
then we store that as confirmed
the reason we've been very robust in the
way we score various positivity
is a data like this so people the
antibodies i showed you earlier working
really well on the cell line
on the left here you can see a bit of
other array tissue
and you can see good staining for spike
but not nuclear capture protein so
the spike is shown in that that white
color
now some groups would score that as
positive we score that as negative
why because if you take the same tissue
if you've got good quality
rna it works on an rna scope you can't
see any transcripts from the virus
in that same part of tissue so
whether that spike protein works well on
the cell lines it works well
in the lung there are certain types of
tissue where it
throws up background one has to be very
cautious in interpreting the results of
virus detection in ffp tissue
particularly from post-mortem cases
here's another example in the middle on
the left-hand side panel you can see a
green
cell that's staining positive of our
nuclear capsules
on the right that same cell is also
expanding positive despite
we've also got other cells that are
staining the spike as well
this tells us that spike and nuclear
capsule should be coincident in their
expression
so again that spike alone staining
doesn't look totally
100
we've gone on to score the different
tissues the presence of virus counted
virus infective cells
and by that i mean virus effective cells
that express both antigens
where we get good evidence of uh virus
positivity by rna state
and by sequencing in the right hand side
you can see we can only pick up various
positive cells
in early stage fast cavity infection
we've never picked up in the late stage
these controls were never picked up in
the nerve or the other control tissue
another interesting result is shown here
so here we're doing viral scope
and we're looking for panasonic keratin
by amino histochemistry
you can see there's a cell here that
stays positive for spike
uh messenger rna it's negative for um
panty k there's another cell at the
bottom there with the yellow o
that again stains positive spike
messenger rna
positive content so we're getting virus
detection
in different types of cells and we're
still looking into exactly what type of
cell
can be infected by character between the
lung
our results are backed up by the geomix
gene expression profiling data
so each of these columns um shows a
different
type of tissue you only ever pick up
such kv2 transcripts in the geomics data
massage v2 tissue as you'd expect
and moreover we only ever pick it up in
the early infectious
uh cases and not the late cases so that
the light brown colored um boxing muscle
plot
shows the results for patient cells kind
of v2a and early
case the other two pieces to the right
of that
are late cases which are negative
transcripts
power of the genomics is it gives you
spatial profiling of rna
you can see that we pick up transcripts
in the alveolus
at much higher levels than what we see
in the blood vessel
again this highlights the fact that we
only see virus in early not late
so here we're looking at the quantity
gene expression data this is bulk
sequencing data
you can see we pick up multiple virus
transcripts particularly nucleotides
spike
and orth on a b in the early stage cases
but not in late stage
i'm now going to move on to talk about
the inflammatory response that's present
in the lung
so here we show you some data uh
acquired on the
vector polaris platform the slides were
stained on the bonds rx system from
leica
you can see very nice aggregates of cd68
positive macrophages in white
in the image on the left hand side
performed a cyber sort analysis on the
bold rna sequencing
that reforms using quantum you can see
that there's a range of different types
of immune cells present
in the cell's kb2 tissues that are on
the right hand side of this diagram here
using computer-aided guided analysis of
the um immunity chemistry results we've
identified
different regions of the tissue
that we've identified as either
lymphocyte enriched or macrophage
enriched or neutrophil unreached
and the frequency of these different uh
enriched areas varies depending on
the type of disease whether that's stars
cov2
antivirus or control tissue
look at these interesting differences in
the vowel in the
immune cell neighborhoods between
earning late so in the bottom right here
you're looking
in red you're looking at the frequency
of cd8 tc abundance
in neighborhood two it's much lower in
the early stage cases in red compared to
the
late stage cases in blue you'll see
differences between disease and see
different things over time
looking at the transcription data we see
evidence of
collagen of kv2
interesting also in mers but not in
rhinovirus or bacterial pneumonia
we confirmed that increase in
origin by english chemistry so here
we're looking at collagen six staining
and the left in normal control you can
see a thin ribbon of collagen six
around the peripheral of those cells on
the right look at our cells kb2 case you
can see the thickened collagen's
positive staining that lung tissue
and in summary we can say that we see a
biphasic pattern of infection and
inflammation
in cysco v2 infected patients
any phase is characterized by high virus
loads and an increase in infiltrating
innate immune cells
late flows by low virus lows and an
increase in infiltrating objective
immune cells
is good evidence of collagen deposition
we're going to move on now to show you
some very emerging recent data from our
group or copy 19 placentinitis
so a small proportion of mothers every
infected massage kv-2 unfortunately
experienced complications in pregnancy
that can include interview drawing
growth resultation
hemorrhage going to your birth and
unfortunately into
uterine death of the uh infant
as various abnormalities seeing the
placenta when this occurs
and here's looking at a piece of tissue
from a cavity 19 positive percenter
and on the right here you can see cd868
positive cells
at the fetal external interface in the
placenta
now looking at another case it's mainly
here by singleplex immunohistochemistry
for
spite on the left and nucleotides on the
right
you see good evidence of staining
two we're using the luna 4 comet
platform to perform
simultaneous spike in nuclear capsule
staining on the single piece of tissue
the nuclear capsules in red spike in
yellow and you see that staining is
coincident so we're seeing double
expression of spike and nuclear captured
protein
in the villus trophoplast
i'm also showing this by responsivity by
institute hybridization using rna scope
so
you can see this first spike on the top
right and off 1ab and the bottom right
of the slide here
finally you can call quant seek on the
placenta samples and you can see
the evidence of virus transcriptones in
a range of different cases
of placentinitis
in conclusion we've shown that you can
apply what the range of
modern immune history chemistry and
institute hybridization and sequencing
platforms
on fft shoes this is particularly
impressive given the
time between taking those samples
between death and taking those samples
and in some cases several days they've
also shown how important it is
to use multiple platforms to cross
validate each other
for a key result
it's a fantastic collaboration between
uh
myself my probably doctor matt q who's
studying here for a phd
in my group kevi as well of course as
part of the ihc facility
we've colleagues at the university of
limerick in ireland
professor paul murray and dr ayna
fennell
give special thanks to dr esther yaud
and dr gareth leopold for
performing the postporting examinations
of course thank the families of the
deceased
making available to tissue for research
purposes
work is being supported by an sfi kerby
19 avid response grant
and thank you for your attention and
your move to take
any questions that you have thank you
very much
and thank you kelly and graham for that
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as
you have time for
so let's take a look we already have
some great questions
coming in from our audience our first
question
can you comment on the identity of the
cells infected by
virus in the lungs
yes uh thanks that's a great question um
predominantly epithelial cells
but we do have now evidence of a
macrophage
infection in certain regions of the lung
so
we've not seen evidence of other immune
cell types being affected
thank you so much and did you do rna
scope on the same tissue that you
analyzed
by ihc
yeah that's a great question as well um
initially we did it on serial sections
so we did the ihd on once uh section of
tissue
and the rna scope on another but we've
recently been able to adapt technique
so we can do rna scope and iht on the
same tissue and that really helps with
validating the staining data
at the protein level but also at the rna
level using rna scope
thank you and we have one more question
from our audience
does your facility accept applications
from
external institutions
yeah um just uh to add on to the last
question that uh that
graham answered um we yeah we we have
had some good success combining ihd and
rna scope on the same on the same slide
um
using uh fresh multiplex um
but we've also recently been uh been
experimenting with combining the the
hyperflex staining with the music
with with rna scope as well which is not
fully validated yet but it's certainly
uh not being a bust to start with so um
it's quite a delicate technique but it
it does have some scope to play well
with to play well with others that's
that's looking really promising um yeah
we
um we do accept um
applications from other institutions
we've we've in the past done
everything from obviously uh internal
motor projects or internal burning
projects
but we've worked um with some external
uk
institutions as well both in
collaboration with uk
with um birmingham academics or just as
a straight academic
service and we've also run um industry
sponsored projects
in collaboration with with local
academics as well as
straight service from industry so we're
we're reasonably flexible
in that respect um we do have a limited
capacity of course um so
those sorts of projects would be
assessed um on
on complexity and and merit
at the time but um we are open to taking
workforce
kelly graham thank you so much for your
presentation today would you like to
provide
any closing remarks to our audience
before we go
yeah no sure um i mean this has
been a huge amount of work and it's a
fantastic collaboration between
ourselves and colleagues locally
nationally
and internationally um i think
it really highlights the need to have
access to well-validated
uh reagents that one can use with with
confidence
i think that's really key everything
builds on the reliability of your
research tools and so
i think it's really important to take
the time to
do those validation experiments to you
know be confident with the results that
you get at the end
thank you would you also like to comment
yes yes i think um what's been
interesting from a facility perspective
is seeing how quickly
um we were able to not just deliver um
you know deliver assays um
inside an academic lab but at a core
facility level we were able to start
delivering
completely new assays with new targets
both antibody and
rna targets through a whole range of
different technologies
all spring up very quickly um and i
think that
that's really promising for the future
of the field that um
emerging trends won't take the there
won't be a big delay
between commercially available products
and
that we've seen in the past and i hope
to see that continue
thank you again kelly and graham for
your time
and for your important research i'd also
like to thank
labruts and our sponsor leica biosystems
for underwriting today's
educational webcast and before we go i
want to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of the
registration and
this webcast can be viewed on demand
laborats will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care everyone
bye-bye